The battle
for eastern
Ukraine was incredibly intense
and bloody this week
as Russia
hammered its neighbor
with all manner of munitions
in Bermuda,
the most hotly contested city
in the region.
Wagner mercenaries
fighting on behalf of Moscow
raised the Wagner,
not Russian
flag near the center of the city.
Where does the war go from here?
Let me bring in my guest today,
retired Admiral
William McRaven
before he retired
from the military in 2014.
McRaven led special operations command
where he oversaw
the US military's most elite
combat units.
McRaven has
another terrific new book
is called
The Wisdom of the Bullfrog Leadership
Made Simple but Not Easy.
Bill, welcome.
Thanks for a good to be with you.
When you look at this Bakhmut situation,
Zelinsky had to make
a very important decision
which was whether to hold the line here.
It will a lot of people to say militarily
this is not significant.
Why devote so much space?
He did it
and he seems to have so far resisted
the Russian advance.
Was it worth it
or was this a lot of Ukrainian manpower
sacrificed for nothing?
Yeah,
I actually think
it was the right decision.
And again, tactically, when you
when you look at it militarily,
as you know, about a month
ago, his advisers
said, look,
we need to do an orderly withdrawal
from Baltimore
because it's just not worth
the cost of the soldiers we're losing.
But I think what Zelenskiy
looked at was, look,
if we lose
Bermuda, plays into Putin's narrative
that the Russians are winning.
And oh, by the way,
it will you know, it will bolster
Russian morale.
It will probably unduly affect
Ukrainian morale.
It could also affect support from Europe
and the United States.
So while it is
just a small tactical piece of ground,
I think it has huge
strategic implications.
I think Zelensky understood this
and I think was the right call.
How does Ukraine win against an enemy
that, in the end of the day
is sort of many, many times bigger
The defense budget is ten times bigger.
The number of people
Putin can call in are so much larger.
So I think winning looks like ensuring
that Russia doesn't achieve its goals.
So when when the invasion
first started, of course,
there were these.
I mean, Putin's narrative
was, we're going to take Kiev,
we're going to come in through hockey.
You've come up through
Crimea, come in through the Donbass,
and we will essentially take Ukraine.
Well, when that didn't work so well,
then he moved the goalposts.
And that was about,
well, we're going to build a land bridge
from Donbass down to Crimea.
And now he is struggling to do that.
So if the Ukrainians can prevent
the Russians
from actually building that land bridge
then I think what it does
is it forces Putin once again
to move the goalposts.
And frankly, sooner or later,
failure is going to be on the radar
for everybody that's watching this
so they don't have to take back the dawn,
but they don't have to take back Crimea.
I know they'd like to.
What they've got to do is prevent
the Russians
from building that land bridge.
And I do think they can do that.
And do you think the key for
the West
is just give them all the weapons
they can get?
Yeah, I'm
a believer
that we need to give them
whatever it takes to win the war,
whatever it takes
for them to be successful.
Now, there's been a lot of discussion
about, you know, do we,
you know,
help with the Europeans
and give them MiG 29
or do we give them attack them
for their high Mars?
You know, I trust General Mark Milley,
one of the finest officers
I ever served with,
and obviously Secretary Lloyd Austin.
Both of these gentlemen have incredible
combat experience.
So if they are kind of withholding
the aircraft
and withholding the attack arms,
I got to believe there's a good reason
for that.
But I think in general,
the administration
has kind of managed the war pretty well.
Now, what they've got to do is decide
whether or not they want to win the war,
and that being the Ukrainians
helping the Ukrainians win the war.